écoute je suis le long du boulevard
berislave ça fait 9 mois que nous
communiquons régulièrement avec Steve
Néron mais c'est la première fois que
nous pouvons le nommer et le montrer à
la caméra on est très heureux
cet après-midi il se balade à pied dans
son quartier à la recherche de quelques
produits frais
au Canada
le Canadien vit à personne en Ukraine il
aura survécu au siège de l'armée russe
depuis le tout début de la guerre
presque toujours confiné à la maison
j'ai un sous-sol qui est pas apparent
depuis sa résidence une des plus costus
du quartier il nous montre où il s'est
caché chaque fois que les Russes
frappait à la porte en étant un tapis
une plante
ni vu ni connu les Russes ne pouvaient
pas savoir des mois à se morfondre avec
sa femme et ses beaux-parents des
Ukrainiens en attendant la Libération
reverson le 12 novembre
il y a eu l'euphorie des trois premières
journées que les gens étaient dans la
rue tout le monde souriait tout le monde
c'était les accolades tellement content
que les fausses soient parties mais
dorénavant
c'est totalement changé ils sont libres
mais comme tous les résidents de redston
et sa banlieue il paie le prix de la
défaite et de l'humiliation des Russes
il y a plus d'électricité il y a plus
d'eau dans la ville
il y a des bombardements
du matin au soir les rues sont désert ce
n'est que sur la grande place du
centre-ville que les gens circulent en
masse pour se brancher au reste du monde
pour être capable de se connaître de
recharger la batterie des téléphones
c'est aussi la course pour trouver de
l'eau à l'arrière vous pouvez voir mon
bassin à ma piscine
depuis ce matin au moins une dizaine de
personnes sont venues chercher de l'eau
pour être capable de vidanger leur
toilettes mais les jours sont comptés
avant le grand froid de l'hiver des
milliers de résidences sont donc
résignés qui ont commencé à évacuer des
urgences
ils ont pris d'assaut les stations
d'essence qui peinent à fournir et les
autobus qui donnent priorité aux femmes
et aux enfants les Russes sont justes de
l'autre côté du niep et continue de
cibler de démolir toute l'infrastructure
essentielle à l'approche de l'hiver
c'est impossible pour les gens de
pouvoir survivre dans ces conditions-là
ça va ressembler à Donetsk
on vient d'entendre encore un tir
d'artillerie il manque aussi cruellement
de médecins et de médicaments expliqués
dont la femme travaille dans une
clinique de santé avec le strict minimum
ma femme avait une équipe de 8
déjà dans la dernière dans la dernière
semaine 5 sont partis ne sont plus que
trois à son équipe donc
les deux autres d'après moi après
quelques semaines de bombardement vont
venir à l'évidence qu'on ne peut pas
rester Steve veut partir lui aussi et
l'armée ukrainienne là d'ailleurs
prévenu
mon secteur avait peu de chance
de ne pas être détruit il se donne
encore quelques jours pour faire ses
bagages et surtout de convaincre sa
famille que oui ils sont libres mais pas
invincibles ici Tamara Alteresco
Radio-Canada Montréal